buenas tardes
no sé qué es más difícil sino si las
mentiras que cabe decir paula
si estar parado en un lugar que la
última vez que viene fue el 7 de
diciembre de 1988
me acuerdo porque se llama era del
colegio
hagan cuentas teníamos 12 18 las sigan
sumando tengo 49 pues lo más difícil se
lo voy a confesar
yo he hablado en 25 años que llevo al
frente de personas conversando he
hablado de economía cuando era aburrido
he hablado de historia política la que
más me gustó era de ideas políticas he
hablado de historia de roma he hablado
de grecia e dictado clases de derecho
constitucional y en la última etapa como
decía mi socia y amiga de parcela paula
médica hablar de felicia organizacional
y durante unos diez años iba a lugares
en colombia fuera de colombia y hablaba
de emociones y bien pero hace unos días
me invitaron a este evento y me
impulsaron a hablar de lo más complicado
que hablaban mi vida y por eso esta foto
que es del emprendimiento femenino
voy a estar un poco emocional hoy una
razón que es el lugar donde estoy y
segundo porque va a hablar de lo que más
significa para mí la vida y por eso esta
conferencia además superwoman cuando me
empezaron a hablar de emprendimiento
femenino empecé a pensar las mujeres de
mi vida no piensen mal estando las
mujeres que marcaron mi vida no dice
otras cuentas
y la persona que más me marcó en mi vida
fue mi super boom en que son mi mamá
porque no hubo nadie más emprendedor en
mi vida que mi mamá el primer acto de
emprendimiento importante mi mamá fue
tenerme a mí ya habrá back up no no se
rían yo era una persona normal de este
espíritu y peso con el tiempo pero así
como el mismo peso que nacen los niños
52 centímetros pero me fui deteriorando
hasta llegar a los 49 años pero el acto
prendimiento real de mi mamá es que
cuando yo tenía 6 años se separó de mi
papá
éramos tres o somos 32 mujeres y yo y de
alguna manera la invitaron de manera
obligatoria acción emprendedora es decir
salga adelante con tres hijos y además
eduque los del es amor y eres ejemplo
facilísimo sí o no muy bien mi mamá que
decidió decidió empoderarse de ese papel
y no se puede buscar a mí me educó mal
pero mis hermanos mayores lo hizo súper
bien de ramis dos hermanas que son
maravillosas yo fui en la parte
defectuosa de la familia pero en ese
camino por ejemplo mi mamá trabajaba de
día y por la noche estudiaba
comunicación social y periodismo en la
unicén la semana que de hecho quedaba
activo en cerca por ese entonces que van
a 71
y les confieso que superwoman quería
decir una persona que siempre tenía la
capacidad de estar en todos los lugares
y era impresionante porque estaba en el
colegio cuando me regañaban está donde
mis hermanas una de mis hermanas mayores
o bastante a la gente le echaban
bastante los colegios y además nos daban
para vivir y además en diciembre nos
mandaba vacaciones muy pro y siempre
pregunto como lo hacía hoy años después
mi mamá murió hace seis años de un
cáncer en el páncreas entendí que
superwomen quería decir aquella persona
que creía en un propósito y cuando se va
a morir ella murió consciente dos días
antes me confesó que yo habían sido unos
propósitos más importantes de su vida
el número imaginario que era su hijo no
su propósito de hecho me gustó un poco
porque ya no me sigo sin un propósito
pero hablando un poco en serio
cuando llegue a este reto que estoy
actualmente que es apoyando el gobierno
en los temas de emprendimiento empecé a
entender que tenemos que cambiar la
dinámica solo que quiero que hoy les voy
a regalar algunas cifras que ente
preocupantes son alentadoras y les valga
de este primero el 88% de las
emprendedoras de alto crecimiento
perciben ser discriminadas es decir bien
complicado es ser emprendedor porque no
nada más complicado yo le iba a todo mi
ecosistema que a todos los que
decidieron ser emprendedores escogieron
la peor profesión del mundo que ser
emprendedor es la más pegada stoke a
quebrarse volver a quedar empresa
quebrarse y la seguridad social hacer un
una planeación de como contrataron sus
empleados pagar impuestos es
complicadísimo ser un vendedor pero
también la más satisfactoria pero
imagínense la fórmula de ser emprendedor
que es difícil que requiere resiliencia
que requiere capacidad imagínense
aumentado que cuando yo soy mujer y si
yo ser emprendedor se nos complica la
vida y les quiero dar además una cifra
para mí
en mi casa éramos cuatro de los cuales
el 75% de las mujeres es decir yo era el
único hombre vale por eso y hago un
paréntesis yo soy una persona que no
distingo ante el rosado el azul el gris
porque para mí todos los colores son
exactamente iguales de hecho en el
colegio me hacían bullying porque yo no
tenía distinciones porque había sido
creado afortunadamente únicamente por
mujeres y esto lo viví viví la
percepción de una mujer que fue una que
siempre que trabajo diferente de ahora
sentía una diferencia frente a su socio
ella tiene un socio hombre y siempre
decía que cuando iba a reuniones hace 30
años la trataban diferente pero además
quiero que nos pongamos en la foto como
está funcionado esto cómo funciona esto
en américa latina y se lo podía juntar
rápido
la mayoría de mujeres iniciaron sus
empresas por oportunidad no por
necesidad uau un aplauso para las
mujeres nosotros
esto que demuestra que ustedes son de
los dos géneros las emprendedoras porque
son aquellas que su plan de vida
realmente se plantean esa posibilidad
por eso la mayoría de artes y oficios
complejos los desarrollan las mujeres
porque son proclives al emprendimiento
pero además vienen de familias o con
historial emprendedor y es un aprecio
maravilloso así como la lengua se
transmite por medio de la mujer también
el emprendimiento set ambiente por el
género el nivel socioeconómico tendrás
el medio alto cuentan con título
universitario eso es muy interesante
ayer estaba en cartagena hablando con
1500 jóvenes y les decía ser emprendedor
no quiere decir no estudiar ser vendedor
quiere decir desarrollar habilidades
para la uti quieren hacer
tiene un olfato de negocio increíble
esto se nota en la casa sobre todos los
que somos casados porque mi mujer es
emprendedora y es increíble como al año
se inventa tres negocios yo me gasto la
plata ella los crea es una maravilla
ayudo disneylandia pero de alguna manera
está demostrado que son ustedes desde el
punto de vista percepción tiene más
tenía el factor para los negocios
emprender en sectores tradicionales son
maduros y se apoyan y eso es muy
importante en los círculos más cercanos
los hombres tendemos a ser mucho más
individualistas en el mundo del
emprendimiento
ustedes son mucho más colectivas y no es
un detalle menor estamos en el siglo de
la economía colaborativa y en el siglo
de la economía colaborativa apoyadas en
redes es muy importante porque la única
forma que un emprendimiento de tony sigo
con las buenas noticias cerca del 90% de
ser vendedoras afirmaron que harían
lo que estuviera en sus manos para
escalar su negocio y eso pasa muy
diferente del tema de género mi mamá
tuvo una fábrica de cocinas integrales
un negocio maravilloso y se quebró tres
veces en el proceso y yo recuerdo siendo
un niño que ella alguna manera la
quiebra siempre la vio como una
oportunidad de reinventarse y alguna
manera su socio era mucho más
conservador de hecho fue la que la llevó
a la quiebra tengo que decirlo porque él
de alguna manera buscaba como el dinero
llevarlo a inversiones personales
idiomas siempre el dinero de la fábrica
lo inventé otra vez en la fábrica y ese
valor colectivo no es menor les cuento
una anécdota aquí que es de las más
bonitas de la historia mi familia en la
última que era mi mamá le quedaban dos
máquinas una cortadora y una sierra en
la fábrica de cocinas y llamó a una
pareja que han sido sus dos obreros más
leales y fieles cosa que las mujeres ven
más que nosotros y le regaló a las
máquinas hoy él es dueño de la segunda
fábrica cocina más grande américa latina
él comenzó su fábrica con estas dos
máquinas
y yo me acuerdo que lo más lindo a la
historia es que mi mamá después tuvo
épocas con económicas muy difíciles
el único favor que le pidió a rafael fue
que le arreglara su cocina nunca le
pidió plata porque ella entendía que el
del mérito es de la comunidad y créame
que sus valores en emprendimiento son
los valores que además que son muy
buenos para la economía son mejores para
el desarrollo social de los países
como lo logramos
asociamos yo hago brotes ahora están en
eventos porque es el lugar donde
generamos conversaciones en mi chat y en
las redes que yo tengo tengo una frase
en la cual estoy convencido la única
forma la única no digo es que hay otra
de transformar la sociedad es
conversando si no aprendemos a dialogar
desde el descenso desde no estar de
acuerdo no vamos a generar un ecosistema
que realmente le dé la vuelta al equidad
y al equidad de género porque hay una
cifra que es dramática se les quiero
contar de los 18 a los 24 años el 79 por
ciento las mujeres estás en actividades
que no son remuneradas a diferencia de
los hombres que solo les pasen el 24 por
ciento
y la única forma de la vuelta a ese
diálogo es girando espacios como esta
reflexión esto no se trata quién es
mejor o peor
se trata que todos somos iguales en los
países civilizados en algo maravilloso
en el mundo empresarial y emprendimiento
todo es exactamente igual participan
mucho más activamente convocatorias
internacionales les gusta mucho más que
los hombres establecer contactos con
clientes internacionales por eso la
mayoría de caras comerciales de las
compañías son mujeres no es por nada
diferente es porque tiene mejores
habilidades que los hombres para
conectarse asisten a más eventos y van a
más
aceleradoras
miren esta cifra y por favor tome la
foto vuelvan a viral pónganse molestas y
molestos digamos vamos a hacer hoy un
compromiso de bogotá mujeres vamos a
transformar esta estadística en cuatro
años y se les acabo de decir el total de
horas anuales dedicadas al trabajo y
cuidado no remunerado 78 por ciento son
mujeres
y yo por eso digo lo digo en mi casa
porque tengo además no solo tuve una
gran mamá sino además en mi segundo
matrimonio anterior es que me gusta
mucho las mujeres entiende casi dos
veces
pues las dos forman a billones de más
toque decirlo porque amar a dos o más
hijos míos y me gusta que los hijos
tengan el segundo apellido distinto
para ser emprendedor se me tienen que
entender pero realmente las transforma
más de verdad maravillosas y yo digo
como lo hacen es porque tienen una
orientación a trabajos de apoyo social
mucho mayor que nosotros tienen la tasa
de desempleo la tasa de empleo femenina
es mayor que la del hombre 12 por ciento
mujeres y 7 por ciento hombres y la tasa
de ocupación ya es bastante simétrica de
un 47 versus un 69
en casi todas las ciudades de colombia
y digo casi porque sólo son 29
departamentos la tasa de informalidad es
mayor para las mujeres y eso sucede
porque arrastramos un tema cultural de
diferencia de género muy complejo
entonces creemos que a la mujer la
podemos emplear de forma no tradicional
y sin seguridad social además y esto
siempre es en teleconferencia en esta
mirémoslo no este punto está económico
no son los del emprendimiento es que
cuando éramos mujeres el impacto social
es altísimo porque los indicadores de
educación nutrición e impacto social
inmediatamente cambio por eso los países
desarrollados donde quedan género existe
menos desnutrición porque hay una
igualdad también en el impacto social y
las mujeres jóvenes son discriminadas
además por los empleadores porque la
piel como potenciales madres
esto es estadístico trabajamos de la
mano con la alta consejería para que a
la mujer con anna maría la consejera
porque pero no todas las semanas y
queremos fundamentalmente dar estas
cifras en ningún momento para alarmar
sino para generar conciencia estamos
todavía en un país cuya diferencia de
género sigue siendo importante como
creemos que podemos hacerlo porque es
muy fácil mirar la parte de atrás y le
voy a decir unas rápidas
queremos hablar en las organizaciones de
diversificación de género que no nos dé
pena que aunque inicialmente se vuelve
obligatorio está bien volvamos lo
normativo 50-50 lo que quieran porque
cuando uno lo vuelve normativo lo vuelve
cultural tengo la fortuna de pertenecer
a un grupo de trabajo con el presidente
que es de equidad género en el que mi
gabinete y les digo algo es increíble
vivir eso cómo se vive se vive desde la
conversación se vive desde el respeto se
vive desde la transparencia yo les
confieso algo uno llega un momento del
vivir en donde se da cuenta de alguna
que éramos retrógrados en pensar que de
la misma forma no todos podemos agregar
valor e incrementar la fracción de las
personas y quitar los estereotipos y
hablo de género pero puedo hablar de
cualquier estereotipo
el lenguaje es lo único que genera
emociones dice humberto maturana biólogo
chileno cambiamos el lenguaje no
hablemos de pro besitos ni pobrecitas
cambiamos el lenguaje porque nuestro
lenguaje además es agresivo una vez se
va a una reunión y cebolla dar la pelea
pues pelea uno va a una reunión
si no cambiamos el lenguaje voy a
conversar voy a cambiar voy a
transformar y 'la invitación' en el
segundo ítem es entendamos que podemos
decir diversificar y una forma de
cambiar esto de género es con el
lenguaje y la última recuperemos datos
en las empresas y contemos lo no hay
nada mejor que quedar descubierto y
cuando uno le dicen pilas que su
compañía el 80 por ciento ese presidente
son hombres uno como que le ha oso se
ocupa
estoy discriminando no les dé pena
contemos las historias también contemos
las buenas historias porque hoy colombia
también está lleno de buenas historias
también contemos la y los divulgadores
virales
es indiscutible que ustedes siguen
siendo tal vez desde el punto de vista
viral los mayores modelos a seguir
porque
cuando veo emprendimientos iba a traer
lamentablemente un vídeo pero allí la
persona que estaba con cartagena no me
lo mandó en la calidad que yo quería una
historia una emprendedora cartagenera
que trabaja con 71 niños en temas del
lenguaje
y me decía hey ayer que lo primero que
le gustó trabajo es porque en la
gobernación de la de bolívar no le daban
cita
porque este tema comienza por ahí es que
además ni siquiera tenemos puertas de
entrada y la puerta de entrada es esta
llave de hoy tengo la fortuna darme
cuenta en la vida por ejemplo personal
que mi vida fue superada por tres
magníficas mujeres en mi primera etapa
mi mamá mi hermana patricia mi hermana
marcela me engañaron mucho no lo voy a
decir porque yo me van a ver ella me
regañaron mucho lo quiero ser
públicamente tengo un pequeño no me
tires son mis parcelas del alma pero
después creé equipos fundamentalmente de
mujeres después creé un matrimonio creó
una familia y tengo una mujer
emprendedora y ella apunta de
conversaciones de ser amorosa de manera
increíble con mi hijo matías y entender
que en las familias se pueden cambiar
las conversaciones en mi familia todo se
conversa a través de la igualdad por eso
nuestro propósito de esta conversación
es que sueño con que en cuatro años no
hablemos que el 70 por ciento de los
emprendedores economía son hombres y el
30 por ciento son mujeres sueño aunque
el 60 por ciento de las mujeres en
colombia sean emprendedoras
y el resto se lo dejemos al resto porque
porque las grandes economías las grandes
historias se han contado en economías y
en países en donde los ojos ven igual y
no en países en donde nos la pasamos
tratando de mirar a las personas
diferentes acuérdense que al detalle muy
bonito en la vida todo sucede adentro
cada uno observa lo que quiere observar
si ustedes quieren observar un mundo
discriminado van a ver un mundo
discriminado pero también se puede
cambiar hay muchos países que han dado
la vuelta y han dado la vuelta con un
espacio de sucesos como hoy les
agradezco mucho y no olviden que siempre
hay una super boom en no solo para
respetar no sólo para querer sino para
hacer entender que hay grandes
mecanismos hace un mes creamos un fondo
que se llama empodera que es un fondo de
emprendimiento de género y ustedes no
saben lo que ha sucedido en las
conversaciones hoy las redes nos
agradecen nos aplauden el hecho no que
estemos hablando de darle más a uno al
otro estamos hablando de que todos
tengamos el mismo espacio para crear un
mejor país muchas gracias
[Aplausos]